proceso es constitucional y de hecho no
lograron detener este proceso judiciales
de procesos políticos realmente no es
judicial es político pues lo trataron de
hacer hace algunos días cuando ron paul
introdujo este proyecto de ley el cual
terminó con una votación de 55 en contra
de esa moción frente a los 45 en su
mayoría republicanos que votaron por esa
moción así que ese es el escenario
político en el cual se encuentra no es
inconstitucional porque hay que entender
dos procesos que se están llevando a
cabo primero obviamente la destitución
bueno ya el presidente no es presidente
pero el motivo por el cual se está
llevando a cabo este juicio político es
porque la idea bajo el artículo 1
sección 3 es la de prohibirle a donald
trump ocupar cualquier cargo político es
decir básicamente prohibiéndole una
proyección política después de su
presidencia que fue bastante tumultuosa
ese es el objetivo y para ello se
requeriría una minoría una mayoría
pequeña es decir 51 votos pero si
estamos haciendo el proceso normal
de dos tercios del senado que se
requiere para que él sea hallado
culpable pero esto va más allá de una
simple destitución bueno y precisamente
hablemos acerca de los apoyos en este
momento en el legislativo usted diría
que si existe una unidad declara entre
los demócratas los apoyos están
divididos de cara al proceso de juicio
político
los demócratas están totalmente unidos
alrededor de esa causa por tanto por el
lado de los republicanos pues no
realmente como acaba de mencionar la
moción que había entregado y mostró que
cinco republicanos se hicieron del lado
de los demócratas mientras que el resto
de los republicanos pues votaron a favor
de esa supuesta inconstitucionalidad que
representa este juicio por este juicio
político o sea que de cara al el
impeachment que se está llevando a cabo
el día de hoy podríamos decir que los
republicanos todavía no están
convencidos de que el presidente cometió
una incitación a esta insurrección que
lo vimos el pasado 6 de enero pero las
evidencias son abrumadoras realmente
porque no solamente fueron las palabras
que le metió el pasado 6 de enero sino
también el intento por revertir los
resultados que se dieron en georgia más
los constantes tweets hablando de una
supuesta de un supuesto fraude electoral
que nunca ocurrió así que toda esa
evidencia fue recopilada y lo vamos a
ver cómo se desarrolla este proceso
político incluso hasta el lunes que es
cuando se dice
los resultados casualmente el lunes es
el día de los presidentes aquí en eeuu
es un día feriado así que vamos a ver si
habrá esa simbología de que el mismo día
el día de los presidentes el ex
presidente de nostrum será acusado por
los cargos que se le imputan en este
proceso gracias a usted de robert y en
france 24 estamos atentos a los
desarrollos de esta noticia